by the time the united states comes to
decide whether to join the war in 1917
they know what exactly what they're
getting into right they're not backing
into the war in the ways that the
european powers did
you know they've seen the devastation
they've seen photographs
they've seen injured soldiers um and
they make that choice anyway when you
say they do you mean the leaders of the
people did
the
the death and destruction reach the
minds of the american people by that
time uh yes absolutely you know that the
we don't in 1917 have the mass media
that we have now but um but you know
there are images in newspapers there are
newsreels that play at the movie
theaters um and of course some of it is
sanitized but um but that combined with
press accounts often really quite
descriptive press accounts um gory
accounts reached you know anyone who
cared to read them you know certainly
plenty of people didn't follow the news
felt it was far away
but but most americans who cared about
the news knew how devastating this war
was
yeah there's something that happens that
i recently visited ukraine for a few
weeks
there's something that happens
with the human mind as you get
away from the actual front where the
bullets are flying
like literally one kilometer away you
start to not feel the war there you'll
hear an explosion you'll see an
explosion you start to like get it
assimilated to it or you start to get
used to it and then when you get as far
away from like currently what is kiev
you start to you know the war is going
on everybody around you is fighting in
that war but it's still somehow distant
and i think with the united states
with the ocean between
even if you have the stories everywhere
it still is somehow distant like the way
a movie is maybe
yeah like a a movie or a video game it's
somewhere else even if your loved ones
are going or you are going to fight
yeah that is absolutely the case and in
some ways that's true even for the home
fronts in in europe you know except for
the areas where
you know in belgium and france where the
the war is you know right there in your
backyard for other people yeah there's a
there's a distance and soldiers of
course feel this very strongly when they
uh european soldiers when they're able
to go home on leave
um often you know deeply resent the you
know that
what they see as the the luxury that
that civilians are living in during the
war
so how did u.s enter the war
who was the president
what was the dynamics involved
and um
could it have stayed out
to answer your last question first yes
right um that the united states could
have uh could have stayed out of the
first world war
uh
as a military power um the united states
could not have ignored the war
completely right it shaped everything
right it shaped uh
it shaped trade it shaped goods and
services agriculture you know whether
you know there was a crop coming whether
there were immigrants coming across the
atlantic to work in american factories
right so the us can't ignore the war
but the u.s makes a choice in 1917 to
enter the war
by declaring war right on on germany and
austria
and in that sense
this is a war of choice but it's it's
kicked off by a series of events
right so uh president woodrow wilson um
has been president through the this
entire period of time
he has just run
in the 1916 presidential election on a
campaign to keep the united states out
of war
but then in early 1917
the germans in some ways
sort of twist the americans arms right
the germans uh sort of high command
comes to understand that you know that
they're stuck
right uh that they you know they're
stuck in this trench warfare they need a
big breakthrough their one big chance is
to kind of as to sort of break the
blockade and to push through that that
the british have imposed on them to
break the uh breakthrough against um
against france
and so they they do
and along with this they start sinking
ships on the atlantic including american
ships the germans know full well this
will draw the united states into war
but the germans look at the united
states at this moment
a relatively small army a relatively
small navy a country that at least on
paper is deeply divided about whether to
join the war
and so they say
let's do it right they're not going to
get any american soldiers there in time
right uh you know it was a gamble
but i think uh probably the their best
chance
they took that gamble they they lost
right in part because french resistance
was strong in part because americans
mobilized much faster and in much
greater numbers than the germans thought
they would so the american people were
divided the american people were
absolutely divided about whether to
enter this war right from 1914 to 1917
there is a searing debate
um across the political spectrum it
doesn't break down easily on party lines
about whether it was in the us interest
to do this whether american troops
should be sent abroad
whether you know
americans would end up just being cannon
fodder for the european empires
eventually
as americans ships are sunk um first in
the lusitania in 1915 then in much
greater numbers in 1917
you know the tide starts to turn and
americans feel that you know our
response is necessary and the actual
declaration of war in congress is pretty
lopsided um but it's not unanimous by
any means
lopsided towards it's always entering
the war yeah yeah
well that's really interesting
because uh
there's echoes of that in in later wars
where congress seems to
nobody wants to be the guy that says no
to war
for some reason once you sense that
in terms of sorry in terms of the
politicians
because then you appear weak but i will
i wonder if that was always the case
so you make the case that world war one
is
largely responsible for
defining what it means to be an american
citizen
so in which way
does it define the american citizen
when you think about citizenship what it
means is two things first of all what
are your rights and obligations what is
sort of the legal citizenship that you
have um as a citizen of the united
states or any other state
and the second is a more amorphous
definition of like what does it mean to
belong right to be part of america right
to feel american to uh you know to love
it or hate it or be willing to die for
it right
and both of those things really are
crystal clear
in terms of their importance during the
war
right so both of those things are on the
table
being a citizen who is a citizen who
isn't
matters so people who had never carried
passports or or you know any anything
before suddenly have to
but also what it means to be an american
right to feel like it to be part of this
project is also kind of being defined
and enforced during world war one so
project you know is a funny way to put a
global war right
so uh can you tell the story perhaps
that's a good example of it of the
james montgomery flags 1916 poster
that reads i want you right a lot of
people know this poster
i think
in its original form it's memified form
i don't know but we know this poster and
we don't know where it came from or most
americans i think
me included didn't know where it came
from and it actually comes from 1916.
does this post represent
the birth of something
new in america
which is a
commodification or
i don't know that propaganda machine
that says what it means to be an
american
is somebody that fights for their
country
yeah so the image and it's in fact i
think one of the most recognizable
images not only in the united states but
in the entire world right and you could
you can bring it almost anywhere on
earth in 2022
and people will know what it refers to
right and so this is a an image that
circulated first as a magazine cover
later as a recruitment poster um where
the figure is uncle sam sort of pointing
at the viewer
with his finger sort of pointing and
saying i want you
right and the i want you is a
recruitment uh tool to to join the us
army and this image you know really kind
of starts as a kind of like i said a
magazine cover in 1916 by the artist
james montgomery flag it initially
appears under the heading what are you
doing for preparedness meaning to
prepare in case war comes to the united
states right at that point in 1916 we're
still neutral
in 1917 um
it's turned into a u.s army recruiting
poster
and
then it reappears in world war ii
reappears generations after you know
like you said it's now uh gets remixed
mimified um it's uh it's all over the
place
i think
for me it's a it's a turning point it's
a sort of window into american culture
at a crucial moment in our history um
where the federal government is now
embarking on a war overseas that's going
to make enormous demands um on its
citizens
and at the same time where sort of
technologies of mass production and mass
media
and what uh we would probably call
propaganda um are being sort of
mobilized for the for the first time in
in this new kind of way well in some
sense is it fair to say that this the
empire is born
the expanding empire is born from the
gnome chomsky perspective kind of empire
that seeks to
have military influence elsewhere in the
world
yes but i think as historians we need to
be at least as interested in what
happens to the people who are getting
pointed to by uncle sam
right rather than just the one you know
whether he's pointing at us um and you
know so so yes he's asking us to do that
but but how do we respond
and the people responded so the people
are ultimately the
the machines of history
the mechanisms of history it's not uncle
sam okay some can only do so much if the
people aren't willing to step up
absolutely they and you know the
american people responded for sure but
they didn't build what uncle sam asked
them to do um in that poster right and i
think that's you know kind of a crucial
aspect that
you know there never would have been
sort of you global u.s power without the
response that begins in world war one
what was the selective service act of
1917
so one of the very first things that
uncle sam wants you to do right is to
register for selective service for the
draft right um and the the law is passed
very soon after the us enters the war
um it's sort of you know uh demanding
that all men first between uh 21 and 30
then between 18 and 45
register for the draft and they'll be
selected by a government agency by a
volunteer organization that's the
requirement to set it up it is a legal
requirement to register not of course
not everyone who registers is selected
but over the course of the war 24
million men register almost four million
uh serve in some fashion what was the
response what was the feeling amongst
the american people to have to sign up
to the selective service act
well i have to register yeah this is uh
this is a bigger turning point than than
we might think right in some ways this
is a tougher uh demand of the american
public than entering the war it's one
thing to declare war on germany
right it's another thing to go down to
your local post office
and fill out the forums that allow your
own government to send you there to
fight
and this is especially important at a
time when the federal government doesn't
really have any other way to find you
unless you actually go and register
yourself right and so you know ordinary
people are participating in the building
of this war machine
but at least a half a million of them
don't right and simply never fill out
the forms
move from one town to another but you
said 20 million did 20 something yeah
about 24 million uh register at least
500 000. is it surprising to you that
that many registered
since the country was divided
it it is and that's what i've you know
sort of tried to dig in to figure out
how did how did you get 24 million
people to to register for the draft and
uh it's certainly not coming from the
top down right
you know there may be a hundred uh
sort of agents in what's now called the
fbi
um you know it's certainly not being
enforced from washington it's being
enforced in you know through the the
eyes of everyday neighbors um you know
through community uh surveillance all
kinds of ways
oh so there was like a pressure
there's a lot of pressure interesting
so there's not a significant like uh
anti-war movement as you would see maybe
later with vietnam and things like this
there was a significant movement before
1917 but but it becomes very hard to
keep up an organized anti-war movement
after that particularly when the
government starts shutting down protests
so as the selective service act of 1917
runs up against
some of the freedoms some of the rights
that
are uh defined in our founding documents
what was that clash like what was
sacrificed
what freedoms and rights were sacrificed
in this process
i mean i think on some level the
fundamental right right is liberty right
um that conscription sort of demands um
you know uh sacrifice um on the behalf
of some for the for
notionally for the protection of all so
even if you're against the war you're
forced to fight yes um you know and
there there were small uh provisions for
conscientious objectors um solely those
who had religious objections to all war
right not political objections to this
war
and some you know several thousand were
able to to take those provisions but
even then um they faced uh social
sanction they faced ridicule some of
them faced uh intimidation
um you know so those liberty interests
both individual freedom religious
freedom you know those are some of the
first things to go
so
what about freedom of speech
what's the silencing of the press of the
voices of the different people who
object uh yes absolutely right and so
very soon after the selective service
act is passed then you get the espionage
act um which of course is back in the
news in 2022 what's the espionage act
the espionage act is a sort of omnibus
bill contains about 10 or different
provisions very few of which have to do
with espionage but one key provision
basically makes it illegal to say or do
anything that would interfere with
military recruitment
right
and that that provision is used to shut
down
uh radical publications to shut down
german language publications um and you
know this is really has a chilling
impact on speech during the war
could you put into words what it means
to be an american citizen
that is in part sparked by world war one
so what is what is that
what does that mean somebody that's
should be willing to sacrifice
certain freedoms to fight for their
country
um
somebody that's
willing to fight
to spread freedom elsewhere in the world
spread the american ideals like what
what um does that begin to tell the
story what it means to be an american
uh i think what we see is a change right
so citizenship during world war one now
includes um uh the obligation to defend
the country right to serve right and to
if asked to die for it right
and we certainly see that and i think we
see
the the close linkage of military
service and u.s citizenship coming out
of this time period
but
you know when you start making lots of
demands on people to fulfill obligations
in turn they're going to start demanding
rights
and we start to see not necessarily
during the war but after more demands
for free speech protections more demands
for for equality for marginalized groups
um and so you know obligations and
rights are sort of developing in a
dynamic relationship oh it's almost like
an overreach of power sparked
a sense like oh crap we can't trust
centralized power
to abuse like to drag us into a war we
need we need to be able to so there's a
the birth of that tension between the
government and the people
it's a a rebirth of it you know of
course that you know that tension's
always there but but uh in its modern
form i think it comes from this
reintensification of it yeah so what
about you said that world war one gave
birth to the surveillance state in the
u.s
can you explain
yeah so the espionage act um you know
sort of empowers
federal organizations to watch other
americans they are particularly
interested in anyone who is obstructing
the draft um anyone who is trying to
kind of
organize labor or strikes or radical
movements
and anyone who might have sympathy for
for germany which basically means you
know all german americans come under
surveillance
initially you know this is very small
scale
but
but soon every government agency gets
involved from the the treasury
department secret service to the post
office which is sort of reading mail to
the justice department which mobilizes
200 000 volunteers yeah and you know
it's it's a really significant
enterprise much of it goes away after
the war but of all the things that go
away this core of the surveillance state
is the thing that persists
most most fully
is this also
a place where government the size of
government starts to grow in these
different organizations or maybe create
some momentum for growth of government
oh it's uh it's it's exponential growth
right that um you know that over the
course of the war
uh by almost any metric you use right
the the size of the federal budget the
number of federal employees the number
of soldiers in the standing army all of
those things skyrocket during the war
they go down after the war but they
never go down to what they were before
and probably gave a momentum for growth
over time yes absolutely
did world war one give birth to the
military industrial complex in the
united states so
war profiteering
expanding of the war machine in order to
financially benefit a lot of parties
involved
so
i guess i i would maybe break that into
two parts right that um
uh on the one hand yes um the there is
war profiteering um there are
investigations of it
um in the years after the war there's a
widespread concern that the profit
motive had played an uh
you know too much of a part
in the war and that's definitely the
case
um
but i think when you try to think of
this term military industrial complex um
it's best you know
to think of it as you know at what point
does the one side lock in the other
right that military choices are shaped
by industry uh stan you know
objectives and and vice versa
and i don't think that that was fully
locked into place during world war one i
think that's really a cold war
phenomenon when the united states is on
this intense kind of footing for for two
generations in a row so industrial is
really important there that is companies
so before then
weapons of war were created were funded
directly by the government were like
like who was manufacturing the weapons
of war
they were generally manufactured by
private industry um uh there were of
course art arsenal sort of 19th century
iterations where the government would
produce its own weapons
partly to make sure that they got what
they wanted
but but most of the weapons of war for
all of the european powers and the
united states are produced by private
industry so why do you say that the
military industrial complex didn't start
then what was the what was the
important thing that happened in the
cold war
i think uh
one way to think about it is it's
the cold war is a point at which it
switches from being a dial to a ratchet
right so during world war one uh you
know the relationship between the
military and industry dials up
you know fast and high and stays you
know stays that way and it dials back
down whereas during the cold war um sort
of the relationship between the two
often looks more like a ratchet yeah
because it becomes unstoppable it goes
up again
in in the way that you start i think
the way the military military-industrial
complex is often involved
discussed is
as a system that
is unstoppable
right and like it expands
it almost i mean if you take a very
cynical view
it
creates war
so that it can make money
it doesn't just
find places where it can help through
military conflict
it creates tensions that directly or
indirectly lead to military conflict
that can then
fuel and make money from
that is certainly one of the concerns um
of both people
you know who are critical of the first
world war and then also of dwight
eisenhower right when he's uh president
and and sort of in his uh farewell
address where he sort of introduces the
term military-industrial complex and
some of it is about the profit motive
but some of it is a fear that that
eisenhower had
that no one had an interest in stopping
this
right and that no one had a voice in
stopping it and that the ordinary
american
could could really do nothing um to sort
of uh you know to kind of to dial it to
dial things down is it strange to you
that we don't often hear
that kind of speech today with like
eisenhower speaking about the
military-industrial
complex so for example we'll have people
criticizing the spending on the on war
efforts
but they're not
discussing the
yeah the machinery of the military
industrial complex like the
the basic way that human nature works
that we get get ourselves trapped in
this thing they're saying like there's
better things to spend money on
versus describing a very
seemingly natural process
of when you build weapons of war that's
going to lead to more war
like it pulls you in
somehow
yeah i would say
throughout the cold war um and even
after the end of it
there has not been a sustained
conversation um in the united states um
about uh about our defense establishment
right what we you know what we really
need
um and um you know what what serves our
interest um and
uh and to what extent um sort of other
things like
market forces profit motives um you know
belong in that in that conversation
uh what's interesting is that in the
generation after the first world war
that was that conversation was on the
table right um through a series of
investigations in the u.s the nye
committee um in britain a royal
commission journalistic expose you know
this would have been just talked about
constantly in the years between about
1930 and 1936
as people were starting to worry right
that storm clouds were gathering in
europe again
yeah but it almost seems like those
folks get
pushed to the fringes
you're made an activist
versus a intel like a versus a thinking
leader
those discussions are often marginalized
framed as conspiracy theory
etc
and um you know i think it's it's
important to realize that
you know uh in the generation after
world war one this was a serious civic
conversation it led to you know sort of
investigations of defense uh sort of
finance it led to experiments um in
britain and france and public finance of
war material
and i think those conversations need to
be reconvened
now in the 21st century
you